s'il faut me away mais bien sûr
évidemment aimé c'est pas mal ton truc
là comment ces sales usa vous peintre et
d internet j'ai le même t-shirt que
lundi puisque je tourne cette vidéo
lundi du mois ce début de vidéo donc
dans quelques instants on va se
retrouver face à guillaume pley et on va
faire un jeu ensemble un jeu à base de
chifoumi ouais mais avant de commencer
j'ai un cadeau pour vous je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez il ya quelques mois
je vous avais parlé d'un instrument qui
s'appelle le diologent avait invité le
créateur pour savoir quel était le
processus qui l'avait emmené à créer ça
ça me fascine un peu il ya beaucoup de
monde parmi vous peut-être même juste
toi juste là qui sont allés sur le site
qui sont les découvrir le produit qui se
sont renseignés et du coup pour me
remercier il vient de m'envoyer un viol
au 1 du totche s
mais je les ai déjà si vous suivez mes
vidéos vous avez vu que j'ai acheté le
mien il ya quelques temps déjà
donc j'en ai un comme ça qui aimait
d'ailleurs merci beaucoup merci à eux je
mets le lien dans la description si vous
voulez découvrir mais moi je vais vous
faire gagner celui ci pour le gagner je
vous mets un post sur twitter
aujourd'hui vous répondez à ce poste
avec le hashtag dual olicard est ce que
ça me fait rien on peut aussi mettre un
petit mot en plus du hashtag ça fait un
peu plus plaisir est la condition pour
participer c'est bien sûr de suivre mon
twitter est de recruter le tweet en
question
maintenant que ça c'est dit je suis
extrêmement ravi de recevoir guillaume
pley sur la chaîne
c'est devenu un bon pote m'a invitée
dans les émissions de radio et c est ça
faisait longtemps qu'on voulait faire
cette vidéo là ensemble c'est ce qui va
se passer
il ya une bonne surprise à la fin ou une
mauvaise ça dépend ce je vous laisse le
suspense en jeu oui ok on donne les
enjeux de ce battle si jamais je gagne
oui tu fais ma promo à la radio pour mon
spectacle
c'est comme ça mais c'est votre problème
je veux même le film et jetant dans la
vidéo exactement comme tu ne gagneras
pas malgré tes trucs et astuces
je peux m'avancer alors contre si je
gagne j'aimerais que tu fasses une vidéo
un ton vraiment pourri par exemple tu
pourrais prendre les ondes de radio
comme thème de vidéos c'est juste ça je
sais je perds je valais fait une vidéo
sur les ondes de radio ça va pas fort
c'est hyper intéressant maintenant mais
ça c'est un million de vues assuré kamal
à ses hôtes imagine je perds je fais une
vidéo là dessus je suis un million de
vues je te demande de me donner tous les
sujets de vidéos et ben et moi si
j'avais tué un million de vues je refais
la promo une deuxième fois y'a pas de
problème effectivement guillaume peut
gagner largement c'est en fait tout est
possible je sais pas ce qui va se passer
on va faire ça en trois manches d'accord
pourquoi il est susceptible de gagner
parce qu'on sait que j'ai des astuces
pour gagner ou chifoumi mais je vais le
dire comme ça ne fonctionneront pas
aussi fluide les gens ont tendance à
commencer par pierre aucaigne temps
farmerama qui est de règle sauf si tu
leur fais un geste avant genre ça ils
vont en parlant de lyon fait un chiffon
me ils ont tendance à commencer par
ciseaux le quillio sûr influencé comme
ça maintenant quelqu'un qui gagne a
tendance à refaire le même coup après
est quelqu'un qui perd a tendance à
changer de coûts dans l'ordre pierre
feuille ciseaux ok c'est pas mal quand
le truc quand même vous regagnez vos
efforts si ça va ça c'est bien beau
d'avoir détruit qu'est-ce que ça
manquait dans ce magnifique livre n'est
ce pas j'ai utilisé la radio gelé ouvert
et oui c'est vrai il est très très bonne
chose on est vraiment à armes égales et
je peux pas utiliser des petits trucs de
mentalist et où je suis vraiment en mode
à poil c'est la première fois que je
fais un truc j'ai pas une longueur
d'avancé
tu veux dire ouais ça partie saturé dit
que général jean commencer par pierre un
ouais ok très bien
attention si fou libye je sens que je
vais avoir une vidéo sur les ondes de
radio très bien sur la chaîne de
montagne et un coût 6 h 15
attention si fou lui s'il faut glee ah
merde
bon j'ai soumis à la naa en fait c'est
pas mal c'est pas mal chifoumi 6
vous me g1 voit ce gros les deux à
égalité
on a eu lieu on avait dix ans cinq coups
la manche mais du coup il faut compter
pas passer c'est le dernier à mort
subite de cette marche marquait chifoumi
chifoumi chifoumi aux petites antilles
lagarde et voilà monta ellis ici sur
cette chaîne
un point pour guillaume pley un point
pour guillaume radio mais manche ah oui
alors à temps est ce que je peux faire
ça comme un film si faut me away mais on
va bien sûr évidemment aimé c'est pas
mal ton truc là moi je veux toujours
commencer sygif omis d'indiquer en plus
de ma mère j'ai vraiment un pierre grau
blair chifoumi oui parce qu'elle écoute
et my pillow faire pieds 1 sec genève
est l'aveu et ben non
s'il faut y aller j'ai vu je joue le jeu
je regarde pas j'essaie mecs se met un
point sans la file en jeu game à la
mairie pour un chiffon me avait si
j'échoue mimi a atteint 3,2 fois de la
montée à wissant dubaï
c'est pas le premier à 5 service lavage
la vidéo sur les ondes radio c'est vrai
les ondes radio puisqu'elle serait juste
utiliser ton truc là c'est un peu comme
il savait guillotine mais c'est parce
que j'avais envie de faire une vidéo sur
les ondes de radio c'est un beau but a
raison parce que c'est très intéressant
vous allez courir les choses allaient
s'arranger tisane à vous passionner
junior alors laisse tomber quoi comme je
me suis viande est sûre les deux
premières je te propose de faire la
troisième quand même sauf que je vais
jouer random et au lieu de décider ce
que je joue je vais prendre au pif ok je
regarde pas qui est là je vais jouer sa
saison chifoumi trois vies
chifoumi je gagne et melaye java et
mélange un mélange juge le mélange
je prends un billet je réfléchis à ce
que je pense et je réfléchis du random
donc vas-y chifoumi y avait maintenant
atteint la barre je retourne à turbine
bien chaque fois c'est pour ça que je
comptais je comptais l'événement s'il
faut y aller mais j'ai l'impression par
tous les moyens de gagner pas bon on va
peut-être trouvé un truc un jour mais
enfin il l'a pas trop me maquille 2000
le hasard quoi si vous me trouvez ça lui
y avait ce jour là c'est que des cours
et bonne vidéo une bonne vidéo a gagné
avec toutes les méthodes du monde
bon vous allez apprendre des choses
bougent et des vidéos saluant les
garages avaient pas me enregistrés
désolé mec faut que l'on fasse tellement
beau j'ai vu depuis la saison j'ai eu
peur donc je ferai de vidéos sur les
ondes radio alors peut-être pas la
prochaine
mais promis elle sortira dans les
semaines à venir d'accord et si elle
dépasse un million de vues je fais trois
fois ta promo merci à toi guillemets le
désir ici votre guillaume clé tous les
soirs sur nrj à partir de 20 heures
cette année ça a changé c'est plutôt et
c'est mortel on a moins de cernes enfin
merci beaucoup abonnez-vous à sa chaîne
tout mais les liens de tacheng guillaume
radio et de la chaîne
gameplay we are exactement l'autre
chaîne qui est qui qui qui s'est relancé
il ya quelques je me suis au dessus dans
quelques jours exact et tard lancé il ya
trois vidéos par semaine en trois vidéos
on en met on en met trois fois par
semaine on vous fait des défis en alice
plein de trucs voit la main s'est adapté
en rejetant le 2-0
yes à lecce kessaci a small est déjà
sorti le temps que je montre celle-ci
n'oubliez pas de laisser un pouce en
l'air c'est que ça vous a plu merci on
vous aime abonnez vous faites des trucs
soyez cool tchad alors si tu crois aux
ondes radio tu peux tu abonnés en
cliquant sur mon rond à moi après il ya
seront à lui mais franchement pas
franchement le rond de fabien l'écart
est quand même vachement plus beaux au
monde qui rompt donc à voter vous plutôt
en cliquant sur leur hôte américain ait
à les faire taire et n'oubliez pas le 29
octobre bien sûr aux grands points
virgules
évidemment merci à vous 12h06 vidéo et
bonsoir